Why we call the Seasons Summer, Autumn, Winter
and Spring
If you’ve ever found yourself wondering
why the seasons are called as they are, well,
wonder no more.
“Winter” derives from the Proto-Germanic
*wentruz, meaning winter.
This in turn probably comes from the Proto-Indo-European
(PIE) *wed, meaning “wet”.
Alternatively, it may come from the PIE *wind-,
meaning “white”.
Either way, the Proto-Germanic *wentruz gave
rise to the Old English “winter” as the
fourth season of the year and the name for
the season has stuck around ever since.
“Spring”, referring to a season rather
than the many other meanings of the word,
first popped up in the 16th century.
Starting in the 14th century, this time of
year was called “springing time” and then
in the 15th century this got shortened to
“spring-time”, and then further shortened
in the 16th century to just “spring”.
The 14th century “springing time” came
about in reference to plants “springing”
from the ground and the like.
Before the season was called these things,
it was called “Lent” in Old English.
“Summer” came from the Old English name
for the season “sumor”, which in turn
came from the Proto-Germanic *sumur-, which
itself came from the Proto-Indo-European root
*sam-, meaning summer.
*sam- seems to be a variant of the Proto-Indo-European
*sem- meaning “together / one”.
The origin of “fall” as a name for a season,
rather than the more common “autumn”,
is not perfectly clear, though it’s thought
that it probably came from the idea of leaves
falling from trees and many plants, particularly
the contraction of the English saying “fall
of the leaf”.
It first popped up as a name for a season
in the later 16th century in England and became
particularly popular during the 17th century,
at which point it made its way over to North
America.
Funny enough, calling autumn “fall” in
England has since passed out of widespread
practice, but has survived as a common name
for the season in North America.
This is not unlike how “soccer” was originally
one of the most popular names for the sport
in England around its inception and a long
time after, which spread to North America,
only to have the name die out in England,
leading many to believe “soccer” is an
“American” name for the sport.
As for “Autumn”, this came to English
via the Old French “autompne”, meaning
autumn.
This in turn came from the Latin “autumnus”,
also meaning “autumn”.
From here things get murky, but it’s thought
“autumnus” probably came from an Etruscan
word and is possibly related to the Latin
“augere” meaning “to increase”.
Beyond that, nobody is quite sure why the
season was originally called that.
Calling the season “autumn” in English
first popped up in the 12th century, though
was a rarity until around the 14th century.
It then began to pick up steam and became
common in the 16th century, about the same
time calling it “fall” popped up as the
name for the season.
Before calling the season “autumn” or
“fall” in English, it was called “harvest”.
Incidentally, you may also wonder why the
seasons are called “seasons”.
The word “season” in this context comes
from the Old French “seison”, meaning
“sowing / planting”.
This in turn came from the Latin “sationem”
meaning “sowing”.
Initially this referred to actually sowing
seeds, but later, as with the Old French “seison”,
shifted definition to refer to the time period
when you sow seeds, so literally “seed-time”.
“Season” in this sense in English popped
up around the 13th century.
It was also around this time that “season”
popped up referring to seasoning food- in
this case from the Old French “assaisoner”,
meaning “to ripen”.